it's intimidating just by virtue of its
size this is not a complicated question
it's just a long ish question so classic
problem solving strategy where the
question is too big to handle you just
bring it down to size and see what you
could learn about the original question
from your smaller version you'll really
trip the question so if you don't I'm
going to do don't worry about having
three mods in a row let's just imagine
you've just got let's pick a deal in are
you just got one long okay we can all do
this question right like wrong enough
even potentially one year we could have
done it this is a long equation I want
to rewrite it as an exponential equation
what exponential equation will it be so
this is how every written it it's easy
to remember with a full-blown since the
base right the base Keeney becomes the
base here and then really all these guys
have to swap places so fine so from here
we can see any number raised to the
power of zero is one so why is it going
to be one in this case okay but hold on
a second then process that you just went
through you can repeat the entire thing
over here it's just that this is why do
you agree with that I do see how I just
a lot of a power of why and how to solve
that all this is just a long wire that's
all so I'm going to take that working
and I'm just going to carry it on this
is why and I've just worked out that is
one if you could reverse it to get you
could do another you could introduce
another substitution thank you so chose
but you know math to you can see I'm
going to do the safety again the bases
said same so this will be 3 to the power
of 1 equals log base 2 of X just like
the Y ended up over there a log base 2
of X 2 then another video and now I just
got to go one more level so it's going
to be 2 to the base to the power of
- happy and you can just really quickly
take this out you can see what happens
you can put a piece in here and then see
what happens as it climbs out and you
will end up I could do it do if you want
this is going to be log base 2 of 8
which is what at 3 so then you're gonna
have to work out go out one layer log
base 3 of 3 which is what one and then
you have to log base 4 of 1 which sure
enough is zero - that makes sense
so two things there number one create
the problem data science okay it looks
intimidating but you know how to solve
super motions with this so take
advantage of that and secondly the only
other thing really is you've got to know
how to convert from a volatile initial
equation just too confusing like we'd
still rearrange the numbers incorrectly
we'll have you so just this is the kind
of thing you put on your paper versus
okay